actuellement.
Ça se tiraille, l'argent reste
le nerf de la guerre.
On lui avait parlé au jour 1
de cette COP, même jour moins 1
de cette COP. Jean Lemire,sasasx
changements climatiques et aux
enjeux nordiques du gouvernement
du Québec. Vous êtes
dans l'équipe canadiene e e e e,
à la COP15.
Bonsoir, monsieur Lemire.
- Bonsoir, Patrice
- Bon, ça regarde pas très bien.
Est-ce que c'est moi
qui dededededededededededededed.
JEAN LEMIRE, émissaire chang.
climatiques et enjeux nordueues
- En fait, si on s'était parlé
hier, je vous dirais que
ça s'est amélioré beaucoup. d ds
très bien, effectivement.
Ça varie beupupup. Je pense que
nous sommes dans une situation
où vraiment, je dirais queututue
basculer, je n'ai pasonononononr
d'ici avec une entente s'il n'y
a pa f f fonds biodiversité
qui est créé.
- Bon, et il y a des gens qui
s'opposent, beaucoup s'opposent
à la création de ce fonds-là....
il faut envisager l'échec
de la conférence de réréréal.
- On n'est pas encore là parce
on a jusqu'à lundi, peut-être
même mardi.
Ce qui est intéressant, c'est
que ce n'est pas juste le fonds,
Patrice, c'est comment il sera,
qui va gérer ce fonds-là.
L'annonce du Canada aujourd'hui
pour le fonds d'environn
mondial, c'est qu'on a déjà...
il existe déjà un mécanisme mais
bon, les pays en développement
aimeraient avoir leur pr
fonds. Pourquo
Parce qu'ils ne veulent pas
avoir du double coususususususue
subvention pour les changements
climatiques, elle ne peut pas
compter à la fois pour
la bioququququququququququququq.
Et on voit beaucoup, beaucoup...
il n'y a pas beaucoup
d'ouverture du côté du Brésil
Donc ils veulent vraiment
leur fonds, auauauauau fonds,
et c'est ça qui achoppe
en ce moment.
Jean, vous êtes là-dedans,
vous, s s s s s les détails.
Prenons le cas du Brésil.
Le Brésil dit à la planète :
l'Amazonie pour X millions
d'acres, je n'en sais trop.
Alors parfait, faites-nous
des chèques."
intéressant parce que vous avezé
de cette coalition pour une
haute ambition, tous ces pays
p p p p p pour le 30 %.
Le Brésil n'est pas  P P P P P ,
ils sont très, très près,
il manque quelques points
y arriver facilement. Mais c'est
une technique de négociation
qui est souvent usususususususun
gros chèque, je vais vous dire
oui de l'autre côté." Donc
on est vraiment dans les jeux de
corridors aiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaiaias
qui sont ici. Évidemment,
pour le public, ça devient
extrêmement difficile à suivre,
une question d'argent, Patrice,
au final. C'est vraiment ça quie
mondial ambitieux, je vous
dirais, mardi prochain.
Mais ça peut jouer encore
d'heure en
- Et qui déterminera si
les chèques sont envoyés ou pas?
et les États-Unis?
- Bien, en fait, je vous dirais,
normalement, la présidence
chinoise, c'est là qu'elle vient
jouer un rôle très, très
d'impair diplomatique, mais
en ce moment est très précieux
parce que quand il y a
un certain silence au niveau
de la présidence, bien, c'est
et je dois avouer que le Canada,
en b b b b b b b beaucoup,
beaucoup d'efforts pour rallier
justement les pays qui auront
les moyens de faire ces fa
chèques. Donc chapeau là-dessus
au Canada devant un certain
en ce moment.
je comprenne, vous dites :enenee
veulent pas signer de chèque,
mais ils sont silencieux.
Deux : les Américains...
les Européens se font tirerc'c'.
- En fait, on s'entend : ça va
c c c c c c c c c c c c c c c ,
par exemple, ce qu'on voit,
noososososososososos. Et donc il
va falloir que les partenaires,
qui sont normalement tous les
ensemble pour essayer de dénoues
évidemPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPaPs
de cette COP.
- Bon, alors je vais relier
aux questions dont les gens
d d d d d d d d d depuis
le début, c'est-à-dire
la protection de 30 % d'espaces
pas à entendre sur ce fonds-là,,
vous repasserez; nous,
on continue puis on déve
parce qu'on a un retard."
C'est un peu ça. C'est ça, laoc.
- En fait, ce que les pays
en développement disent,
participer à une très grande
ambition, qui est justifiée
évid d d d d d d d d d d d d d t
ce que les scientifiques disent.
Donc si vous voulez qu'on ait
vers le 30 %, bien, donnez-nous
riririririririririririver."
Donc en gros, on comprend
c'est simplement, Patrice, queee
en climat par exemple, il y a un
fonds de 100 millions
il y aura un nouveau fonds pour
pertes et préjudices qui a é
biodiversité. Je comprends aussé
avec les pays riches qui disent:
"Bien, ça fait beaucoup,
beaucoup de fonds à gérer
et beaucoup d'argent."
vevevevevevevevevevevevevevevevi
on veut créer ce fameux moment
Montréal, ça va prendre
des sous.
- Et s'il n'y a pas de moment
Montréal, si on ne s'entend pass
progrès." Si on ne s
il arrive quoi? On se revoit
quand exactement?quququququququ.
Les scénarios pour un échec
ne sont pas... n'ont pas été mi.
On sait par contre, on l'a vu
ce matin, il y a 116 pays
Ça, ce bloc-là ne bougera pas.
Est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
bien nous, on continue surnsnsnl
reste encore beaucoup d'espoir.
- OK, il reste du baseball
- Exactement. On est comme...
on rentre dans les séries, là,vo
sur la glace.
suivre ça en fin de semaine,
les gens vont
les butins de nouvelles, un peu
partout, dans les journaux, et
je le rappelle, mais peut-être
lund
mardi matin, on verra. Qui sait?
Jean Lemire, on se reparlera.
Merci beaucoup.oioioioioioioioii